thank you
[Music]
Nick is gonna love this one I don't
think so there's a there's a comparison
that's going around that's kind of like
ruffling some feathers uh I'd be ready
for this and uh it is the paid disparity
between the highest paid WNBA player why
would I love this oh
wait
in the highest paid Fitness coach no
paid uh NBA player no even worse okay so
look at this the Denver Nuggets mascot
makes 625k a year really so much yeah
the massive mascot are you kidding 6 25k
a year did he just get punched in the
face by Conor McGregor is that is it the
Denver Nuggets yeah yeah yeah yeah he
did he did he had to go to the hospital
I rather watch the mascot during the
halftime show than the actual basketball
game all right A lot of people have that
opinion honestly the highest paid WNBA
player makes 228k
all right you know what I have a
question they're not doing Apples to
Apples no yeah yeah all right here's the
question
what is
the highest paid cheerleader in the NBA
I don't know I don't believe are they
getting more or less than the wmb might
be like 50 Grand maybe yeah
the WNBA player is doing making more
than the cheerleader
that's that's
got in a woman that's not the same thing
well the the comparison is it's a woman
to woman yeah and then one is an athlete
and one is a dance athlete it's a dastly
yeah
but then it had like uh like certain uh
WMA players tweeting I can learn to be a
mascot
that's funny if they make it your size
maybe yeah but again
within that like that pay Gap disparity
of where it's based on the money that
comes in yeah Denver Nuggets are rolling
in dough right for the championship too
so they are gonna pay any affiliate of
the company a lot is the person writing
the article complaining
no I think they're trying to stoke a
complaint the way that I see things is
like instead of complaining learn from
models that have been successful so in
the UFC
Ronda Rousey has been able to get paid
way more than any of their male fighter
like probably 90 of them great example
so how do we get WNBA like what's the
marketing strategy or business strategy
how do we get that like that and also
too to piggyback off Barts the UFC ring
girls at male MMA fighters have made the
same complaint about the UFC ring girls
making more money than the actual MMA
fighters yeah right yeah because
sometimes a purse is lower than what
they're paid to be there right exactly
but when you look at the UFC ring girls
they're such a big part of the brand of
the UFC and the whole experience to the
whole show right and they always like
acknowledge the ring girls as like the
celebrities of like the because they all
make six figures and above and then some
of the starting Fighters will only make
like 10 grand yeah absolutely and then
you extrapolate that to maybe the mascot
of the Denver Nuggets it's like they're
a giant well I don't know about well now
this year they've definitely been really
big because they won the championship
they're the number one team in the west
which is the most competitive
um
um division yeah conference right and
then you have the mascot who's like
who can also dunk by the way yeah dude
he doesn't he do like a halftime show
he's like running up and down the
[__] uh he's not just a guy just
[__] around like this guy has actual
skills yeah yeah and he can die what
he's doing he's punched in the face
you went to the hospital dude I can't
even dunk without a mask on yeah costume
on but also it goes back to what bar
said it's the NBA is a way bigger Market
than the WNBA unfortunately but that's
just what the numbers are the question
is how do we get more people to go to
WNBA games well the players I feel like
the players have to be willing to like
change they don't want to change [__]
they don't want to change all of the uh
interviews they're they're like oh we
don't want to change the height of the
the basket because I've been shooting on
like a 10 foot all my life even though
but Shaq recommended it remember he
checked brought it up that's what he
said I didn't say it start dunking
yeah they could just they could just
play because it's entertainment even
though it is athleticism it is
entertainment right so like yeah no
sorry I was gonna say the W there's no
WNBA player who's waving her gun on
Instagram live like John Morant is like
think about all the news that go you
need more Capers surrounding the league
well you think about all the the biggest
players in the NBA they all have some
sort of controversy they all have
honestly you need drama sales and drama
is free market the WNBA they're they're
squeaky clean I feel like a lot of the
best basketball player like I can't tell
you who the best best the best WNBA
player is but I can tell you who the
best MMA uh women's fighter maybe they
would benefit from having a narrative uh
Builder like the MMA has yeah or WWE
yeah imagine that I mean that'd be great
because sports fans like we don't watch
it and I was having this conversation
with a client of mine she was she was
talking about like oh yeah like my
husband always gets mad at me for
watching uh reality TV shows and I was
making the point that Sports is just
male reality reality right but just in
the form of something else right because
it's like what people want to talk about
is like how is LeBron going to play
against the finals with a with a torn
ACL or whatever like how is he gonna
perform is he getting too old like all
these questions we care about we want to
hear it's like keeping up with khabibs
exactly oh dude what watch that show you
kidding me Rock Solid oh that's another
bear today
there is a lack of that potentially
maybe that's where they could start
where they can get more eyes like what
would be cool is like if we can get
everybody who's
um
like what if this happened if you
complained about the pay disparity you
automatically get your card charged for
season passes
to the people that are complaining don't
even they're not even into sports
they're not even going to the game
there's this one street interview right
and then this guy asked a bunch of girls
they're like so do you guys know who
Floyd Mayweather is and they're like
yeah
um he's that boxer yeah so if he
identified as a woman do you think it
would be fair if he starts fighting in
the women's league and then they're like
yeah completely they're like women can
be just as strong as men all those girls
look unathletic they don't look like
they've ever played Sports it's just
death sentences this is the thing so I
think I would kill a guy that's that's
the issue is people that have nothing no
knowledge just imagine that yeah this
girl's the same size she has the same
strength like they're they don't even
know they're just making decisions and
then so the people that are complaining
about most of the stuff I truly believe
it's coming from ignorant folks that
have no idea like women are that are in
the sport are probably embarrassed of
some of the other complaints coming from
[__] idiots yeah so like
and I also think like um the argument of
like like gender discrimination in like
income disparity right A lot of it is
rooted in outdated ideas of how men view
women for example like it was rooted in
truth because there was a time when
they're like oh girls aren't allowed to
work in this field because they're just
not smart enough or whatever right yeah
but we've gone long past that point it's
about economics and practicality what
company doesn't want a high performing
individual to make money for them that's
how it works right whether it's male or
female they want the most effective
method to extract the most income out of
this person's performance
these people are still stuck the people
that are making this argument are still
stuck on uh men don't like women and
don't respect women therefore they won't
pay women the same rate which is a very
victim mindset yeah not only victim but
a very incorrect yeah mentality of how
companies work like that was true during
the 1930s
but we've gone way past that point and
companies just want
the best way to make income
so for example in the NBA right like
it's making a ton of money so they can
pay their athletes x amount of dollars
these people don't understand basic
economics if the company is making a
hundred bucks how can they pay the
player a thousand dollars it doesn't
make sense but that's what they don't
understand is like if the company is not
making anything and they're losing money
how are they going to even survive
opening but they they deserve more pay
is what they say right so I don't care
you just gotta just gotta pay them worth
somehow yeah right and then you look at
all the big stars in the NBA why are
they big stars they sell tons of jerseys
they sell merch all out they're dropping
50 points a night they're exciting they
they have story lines behind them and I
feel like that's not out of the realm
possibility for the WNBA to have just
like say they're just one girl who's
just a [__] Phenom yeah who just
talks [__] to everybody you know like no
but honestly like because people want to
kind of see that [__] like why is Ronda
Rousey popular why did when Ronda Rousey
came to the MMA
um when she was fighting in a different
promotion that's not the UFC Dana White
the president of UFC was like we will
never have women's MMA fighters we will
never have that that's just not what
we're gonna do wow he saw her fight one
night and saw the pop that she brought
out and all the fans that came out and
all the excitement that she brought and
he goes all right we're gonna make a
division and we're gonna put Ronda
Rousey as she's gonna she's gonna fight
for the title like it was just that
simple it was clear like she has
something yeah I have a use for her and
once she started losing what happens she
doesn't find the UFC anymore she goes to
WWE I heard she's making more money in
WWE did in WFC definitely yeah because
she's still doing what people want to
see exactly what's that one chip that
was uh that got popped for marijuana and
she couldn't uh
chat star oh yeah that's right yes it
was her last name Richardson or
something but just a little bit of drama
everything single celebrity comes out
and Baxters
and then boom she gets like I think a
Nike contract like you you need to add a
little bit more of that excitement to
grow the sport and I think everyone in
that that's part of the discussion is
probably too sport focused yeah like our
basketball is just as good how come they
don't watch it yeah but you need the
whole package like you know what I think
it is it's like Olympics versus NBA or
NFL or like any other actual major
sports that are
happening like every year it's
entertaining there's a whole like
industry behind it whereas the Olympics
it's more like yeah you're just watching
it for that sport exactly but then it
doesn't go anywhere yeah like men's
France basketball yeah they probably
make even less than the WNBA yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah and make people give a
[__] like why do we care why do we pay
attention to the 100 meter sprint Usain
Bolt yeah right like we watch that
because we want to see this guy who's
who doesn't talk much but who's
exceptional you want to see the guy that
[__] Sprints looks at second place
I mean Michael Phelps right it's not
because he was a man that he was it's
because he's a Phenom it's it's crazy
it's a story 15 gold medals like that's
insulting he's gonna yeah he's gonna
break the record of like Mark Spitz or
whatever this freaking thing I think
like anything it's just such a common
sense solution to me it's like if you
really believe that something should
earn more money yeah give your money to
the thing and talking about more WNBA
games than most women I know I've been
to like eight that's why I've been to
none because I don't believe in that
I've been to none
thank you